turkey is in no doubt about who's
responsible for the failed coup attempt
in July it's pointed the finger squarely
at Fethullah Gulen a reclusive Turkish
cleric living in exile in Pennsylvania
who said to control a global network of
businesses schools and media interests
my guest here in Frankfurt is his
movements chief representative in
Germany is the whole enterprise as
benign as it claims to be
or is there a darker side
a John Carrick are you
welcome to conflict zone thank you for
inviting me let's go back to the
attempted coup in Turkey in July
turkey blames Fatone of Gulen and his
followers for this their right not they
you were responsible for this I think
they are wrong because the hizmet
movement is engaged in education and
dialogue for 40 years now hizmet
movement is the so-called movement yes
yes but we call ourselves hizmet
movement because it is not a cult so we
don't reduce our activities on mr. Gulen
and I think that the accusations of
erred one absurd because Fethullah
gülen's preachings you can read them in
about 70 books which consists of 15,000
pages and he's always been a democratic
voice he has always been someone that
focused on human rights but he's not
doing a very good job of convincing the
international community
last week the European Council on
Foreign Relations a very respected think
tank called your movement opaque and
secretive and said there is enough
evidence linking followers of Gulen to
the coup but evidence pointing to
Buland himself remained scant so you're
not doing a very good job of convincing
people in Europe either of your
innocence I think we have to work on it
because until now nobody was interested
in the hizmet movement
my question was you're either guilty or
innocent we are innocent but I think the
problem is that I think the problem is
that nobody was interested in the work
of the hizmet movement for 40 years now
and now since Iran has defined us as a
scapegoat and under this pretext he is
cleaning and purging the whole state
everybody is suddenly interested in the
hizmet movement so studying for a long
time and the European Council on Foreign
Relations says your movement has
infiltrated the state enabling it to
orchestrate conspiracies to get rid of
political enemies so it seems as though
they've been studying you
quite a lot over the years I think the
accusation of infiltration it comes from
the Kemalists this is very distraught
because the Kemalists saw the state as
their own and nobody who has to add
different thoughts or different beliefs
had the possibility to serve for the
state and this is for example why Gulen
said it is the right of every Turkish
citizen even if he is the believing
Muslim to serve for the state and this
is this is not infiltration than just
serving the state we have the British
ambassador of government official in
Ankara saying he had no difficulty
accepting what the Turkish government
was accusing your movement of namely
involvement in the coup he says
circumstantially without prejudging the
judicial process it looks to me a pretty
convincing a convincing case of the
people who are studying you looking at
you close to in Turkey I'm not convinced
by your arguments nor by your
professions of innocence well there are
different opinions as well for example
John Esposito the famous expert who also
analyzed hizmet for a long time there
are several other German experts for
example there are experts in the u.s. in
Britain
you're guilty but on the other end there
is focus for example Biden carry that
alts who all say that there is no
extradition going to be because there
are no evidences so what terms I haven't
said they're going to look at the
evidence if turkey produces it they
haven't said there's no evidence the
evidence if it is provided by Turkey but
there is no evidence as well but there
is no evidence that is linked to the to
the coup so the Turkish government it
seems to me has no interest in
investigations this has always been like
this for the bomb is also on Foreign
Relations as there is enough evidence
linking followers of Gulen to
the cool you say there isn't any they
say there is but there are also it is a
coup and there are a lot of military
personnel a Kubik that is a coup attempt
and there are a lot of person that are
involved in such an egg course we don't
know your denials are actually worthless
I know there are for it there may be AKP
people that have been involved that may
have been Kemalists that have been
involved and I think the Mosel may have
been involved in it there there are a
lot of people for example of course they
can be involved but it's a meaning but
it has nothing to do with the core
values of hizmet for example if the
Catholics somewhere in the world commits
a crime it has nothing to do with the
Catholic Church or the Pope so they can
always be people that commit crimes
hizmet is a very heterogeneous that
consists of maybe 5 million people on in
Germany we are about 100,000 people and
they all have different opinions they
all have different characters so you can
never say in a social movement that is
such broad and heterogeneous nobody
committed so you might have been some of
your people might have been responsible
for this coup attempt they might have
been yeah no I don't think that they
have been responsible they could have
been responsible I think what we need
your angle here saying that some of them
might have been if I understand you
correctly you know this is not a very
emphatic denial I think what we need our
investigations and it seems to me as if
everyone has no interest in
investigations because I don't know why
he isn't interested in it but he can
open the evidence to an international
organization for example that comes and
looks at the evidences but he doesn't I
think he does not have an interest in it
because he defined the scapegoat and he
is purging the state from all critics at
the moment he's not the only one who's
pointing the finger at you but let's
have a look at your track record here
because despite your current emphasis on
moderation and tolerance your movement
has in the past supported actions by the
Turkish government that were anything
but
moderate or tolerant in fact they were
pretty repressive weren't they the
European Council on Foreign Relations
says that between 2008 and 2013 with the
help of the Turkish government the Gulen
movement persecuted political enemies in
show trials dozens of these trials were
held hundreds of military officers
generals journalists writers bureaucrats
were imprisoned with the aid of your
movement so don't think so your track
record isn't great when it comes to
moderation and tolerance the values that
you preach today I think you have to
read turkey within Turkey
and if you look to the late 90s you see
that Turkey was a very oligarchic system
it was very author Italian and when
Ayrton came to power he promised
European values he promised from the did
you think did you or didn't you
we didn't I think this has to be
investigated and then everybody who
committed to crime everybody who is
guilty no matter to which you if weather
is Kemalists
ela V Kurt Turk or whether is
sympathizer of guellen-- everybody who
commits a crime has to be investigated
and to rest he has to face the
consequences everybody who commits a
crime has to face investigations and has
to be trialed and the point is that
everyone is never interested in
investigation so we don't know who was
behind all these things but a lot of
people as I said before have been
investigating new movement in 2007 the
New York Times reported that much of the
evidence that had been presented in the
trials the show trials we talked about
which implicate your movement much of
this evidence appear to have been
fabricated so this is something you have
to ask the politicians so your move
because your movement according to these
reports was involved in fabricating
evidence in 2010 in the sledgehammer
so-called sledgehammer trial which led
to 300 army
officials being jailed for allegedly
another coup attempt your movement acted
as cheerleader fighting angels because
of fabricated evidence but your movement
was cheerleading championing I think
that it was a big mistake and I must say
that I'm very sad about for example the
politics of publishing from the man
media house because it is using which is
a Gulen affiliated it is but maybe
you'll have a look at what Glenn said at
that time Gulen was crying when he heard
that for example generals were very
nasty and he and he for example he for
example defended a chick who was
imprisoned at that time too he said
nobody should ever invest because in
getting custody for writing negative
things about me so I think if you look
to what they some people of the movement
did into what Gulen says for example you
see the contradiction this has your
media the media that were affiliated to
the Gulen group were supporting these
investigations that were based on
fabricated evidence everybody who
fabricated these evidences has to be
investigated this I believe indeed but
this is part of your track record mr.
carraclough Yin we have a story of
fabricated evidence ruined lives years
wasted in jail on false charges and your
movement was partly responsible for this
I don't say wholly but according to the
reports at the time partly responsible
in 2014 when an Istanbul court ordered
the release of 230 people the
Constitutional Court decided that the
defendants rights had been violated you
took part you have to put up your hand
and say we are also responsible for
violating the rights of these people yes
of course but if you look back for
example to a lot of articles and books
that were published in two thousand
eight and nine you see for example John
Linder and a lot of other critical
journalists of aired or
at that time they welcomed the ergenekon
and Barrios investigations Batak because
everybody saw it as a step towards
democracy but I think what happened then
is that everyone missed used these
trials in order to start a purge so I
think it wasn't just I think everyone is
responsible for the fabricating of such
was your political enemies jailed your
political enemies discredited and jailed
you were very happy about I don't think
so because for example I took the book
of Alma took and put it on my home page
I was at that time publisher of the
German Turkish newspaper and I put his
book about the Gulen movement that was
very critical and he was in custody
I put his book onto my home page because
it is absurd freedom of thought freedom
of press is his book the army of the
Imam and he said at the time about your
movement if you touch them you get
burned whether you're a journalist and
intellectual or a human rights activist
if you dare to criticize them you're
accused of being a drug dealer or a
terrorist so he was saying what the
price was of writing something about
your movement and I defended him just as
I said did you say I've defended him but
your movement was still responsible him
also so I think we have to distinguish
between or maybe you don't control your
movement anymore if that's the case
maybe you don't control us of course
because it is a very broad and
heterogeneous meant there are about
maybe 10 million students pupils that
finished hizmet schools so it is a very
broad it is a very broad movement and
you cannot control it it is not the aim
of hizmet to control these people they
are all free they can do what they want
and to say that everybody was able this
is an easy excuse to make
this is easy no news you are tightly
controlled movement know if there are
especially in government circles where
there are Imams for the police Imams for
the government Imams in in particular
government departments which corral your
followers and direct them and make sure
that they are toeing the line of freedom
of thought freedom of emotions freedom
of press our core values that we stand
for the state of law the separation made
shape the separation of powers well I
also say that this book heads has to be
had to be published this is why I put it
on my home page because it is absurd
freedom of press freedom of thought is a
human right and nobody can work against
it and if somebody does there is they
have to be investigations and they have
to be trials so does a man person should
have been of course these were your
papers papers that were in thrall to
your movement if they knew that these
that they were fabricated proofs and
they published it by knowing it then of
course they have to be investigated
everybody no matter whether he is good
and sympathizer or not has to be
investigated such things never have
something to do with our core value so
what I say is it is a human right that
every individual himself is guilty for
what he commits you cannot make me
responsible for something that hizmet
followers in Turkey do so the guilt the
individuality of guilt is a human right
and you have to investigate these people
you have to taken to trial and then they
have to face the consequences but just
is the meritorious before erred one has
no interest in this investigations and I
am asking myself why he hasn't this
interest maybe because he self behind
all these
the European Council on Foreign
Relations talks about your groups
interest in law enforcement it cause it
almost obsessive says it sets it apart
from all other religious groups in
Turkey and it draws attention to a
sermon given in the late 90s by
Fethullah Gulen where he advised his
followers to continue living incognito
inside the veins of the state until
enough power has been amassed you must
move in the veins of the system he's
reported as saying without anyone
noticing your existence until you reach
all the power centers you must wait
until such time as you've got all the
state power until you brought your sight
all the power of the constitutional
institutions in Turkey this is a power
grab being recommended by Fatah Laguna
and the leader of your movement isn't it
a slow gradual infiltration of state
institutions to grab power towards
democracy yes it looks it looks like
because you have to consider bunch of
trials and terminated evidence that's
what it's been to know maybe you look
into the 90s of Turkey there were so
oligarchy and to generate Arian that you
were quite happy there was there was an
oligarchic authoritarian States and
believing Muslims Armenians Christians
Kurds had no opportunity to serve for
the Turkish state and when a preacher
now says it is your right as well to
serve for your country entered into the
ministries and into all areas of state
it is not infiltration it is
normalization and if you look into
preaching mobilization and if you look
into the preaching no no if you look
here for example you infiltrated the
state in order to democratize yes that's
it and this is what it will show trials
were to democratize and for example if
you attacks on people who wrote books
about you was also to democratize free
society rages suggest you have to remind
these deeds I think it is aired one
because if you look to what Gulen wrote
for example in 94 and 96 and
different interviews with with secular
journalists Gulen always said that there
has to be a separation between religion
and state and that there has to be a
democratic state and he always said that
he has nothing to do with politics
doesn't matter what you say all right
it matters what you do what you were
doing in the background in a state
institution for example when you look to
the first years of Earth one when it was
so that need friends with him yes what
happened in this year good friends they
work together to eliminate their
political enemies no what happened in
the city is active for example we had
minority rights promoting in this years
the Kurds had their right to speak their
mother tongue we had advised that act
that were getting their their gem IVs
their prayer rooms and we had for
example a lot of minority rights that
were given to the Armenians to the
Christians and these were values that we
promoted but when everyone came to
suffer at the same time as you were
bitter lively interesting people from
the army and journalists were being
repressed as well I think the same time
everyone started his perch in these
years and now it looks because he has
found a good scapegoat a specificity
education movement whose preacher is
living in the Pocono Mountains who is
very spiritual and who lives a very
reclusive life you can't find a better
scapegoat and this is what everyone did
he now probably now projects everything
everything on hizmet he even said that
the earthquake of 99 was a proposal made
by by by Gulen I understand it doesn't
make you angels even if mr. Erdogan has
done bad things
it doesn't make you angels in 2012 the
New York Times described a culture of
fear around your organization they said
it was so endemic that few people in
Turkey would talk openly about your
group on the phone for fear that their
conversations would be monitored and
there would be consequences as far back
as 2005 the US consulate in Istanbul
sent a cable to Washington marked secret
it was about
your group the cable expressed deep and
widespread doubts about your movements
ultimate intentions disturbingly it also
spoke about pressure the movement
applied to people who you had drawn into
your circles it says we have anecdotal
evidence of the pressure that the
various circles of his that's Gulen's
movement put on people they've drawn in
for instance severe pressure on
businessmen to continue to give money to
support good honest schools or other
activities moderation and tolerance you
preach not pressure
the reality is you pressure people to
give you pressure people to toe your
line you pressure people to take the
politics of Turkey in the particular
direction you want it to go in that's
the reality isn't it I don't think so
because just as I said Gulen for example
mode late Pope John Paul he met with the
Armenian patriarchy met with Bartholomew
he met with it's like a lever the chief
rabbi of Jews in Turkey why all the
secrecy if you if you're going out of
meeting all these people and trying to
present a public face why all the
secrecy no one has managed to reveal the
financial and administration
administrative backbone of your
organization that from that from a
professor at Stockholm University's
Institute but this is very transparent I
think because if you look into the
institution's fundings you will see that
they all found it by regional firms by
regional institutions they are found by
for example in Germany we are funded by
people that live here so the financials
the aims and the structures are very
transparent they are everybody can
follow them and you say that but
everybody points in fact to the secrecy
and the lack of transparency and one of
you one of the college is the point of
their teachers who worked in one of your
charter schools and you have the largest
number of charter schools in in the
United States said the way your system
worked was that a Gulen organisation
controls the real estate companies that
owned the schools they charge rent to
their own schools and taxpayers foot the
bill they refused to answer public
record requests falsify attendance
records and cheat on standard
test this is one of the teachers who
worked in your organization and saw the
methods man called Matthew do you know
what Glen show the methods who saw the
methods that your movement applied Glen
said if there is any school that does
not make transparent and it has such
mistakes then they should be closed
stakes if there are any problems any
crimes committed by members by
volunteers by institutions that have a
connection with hizmet then they should
be investigated they can be closed they
should be we are all investigating them
for example there are a lot of articles
that we are writing that are very
self-critical that we are we are
discussing about these issues we are
discussing about the mistakes that is
made made in the past for example when
everyone tried to purge his criticals
after igano-kun
we are all discussing about this we are
also discussing about for example people
that leave the hizmet movement and they
say that they felt pressure on them
because these are things that have
nothing to do with our core values
people are free we are focusing on the
individual and not on the state and not
on the society and we are itself
predictable and we are working
why shouldn't Fethullah Gulen go back to
Turkey and clear his name in a trial in
Turkey they want him back why doesn't he
go back he's if he's done very well in
the courts in Turkey yesterday years
he's proved his innocence many times and
well you can ask the same question what
case I can ask the same question to John
tinder why doesn't he go back because
there is no element I was asking you the
question there is no fair trial in
Turkey there is no independence of law
there is no energy has many fair trials
and has succeeded in all of them as far
as because he never was guilty and they
had some choice is it were those fair
trials or not or was he acquitted wrong
we never had such a dictatorship such as
now is it only a fair trial when you win
I don't think
it has to be an international
investigation this is what I believe and
then whether he is guilty or not has to
be decided because Aaron puts his
personal interests above States he puts
his personal interests above law and
above judiciary and in such a situation
it's a suicide to turn back to Turkey
there are two phases to your Gulen
movement and there as Dani Rodrik
Harvard economist has said should be
clear to any objective observer the
Gulen movement goes much beyond the
schools charities and interfaith
activities it also has a dark underbelly
engaged in covert activities such as
evidence fabrication time to admit there
are two phases to your organization on
them I think that hizmet is a very
heterogeneous and broad movement there
are a lot of people that are engaged and
they of course can have mistakes they
can commit crime and they can do such
things but what has to be done is that
these people have to be investigated and
trialed and our core values are dialogue
education and promoting human rights and
this is what we are trying to do and
this is also why we are very
self-critical critical and why we are
working on bettering these things and
this is why we promote democracy in
Turkey at the moment Jericho thank you
very much for being on campus thank you
you